today is Friday August twenty second and
you're watching gamespot news I'm Chris
waters here to send you off into the
weekend with a brain full of news and a
pocketful of Dreams the news will be a
recap of the top five stories of the
week and the dreams well you're gonna
have to put on your special dream pets
with your dream lined pockets for
keeping your dreams in and then you'll
dream an extra big I don't even know I'm
saying any more news a new free update
arrived for grand theft auto online this
week that takes players on a ride into
the the san andreas flight school update
introduces new jets and helicopters for
use in new aerial solo challenges as
well as new land vehicles gamespot zone
Rob handlery put together an amusing
breakdown of all the new stuff and how
the mission payouts have been tweaked
you can find the full video on the site
but here's a sneak peek god I'm such a
thanks rod oh you know been foolish hey
oh that looks good oh yeah here we go
punch it look alive catch ya
good good yeah folks looking forward to
minecrafting on their PlayStation fours
are gonna have to wait a little longer
than expected after the game failed
Sony's final round of certification
testing developer 4j Studios tweeted
that they are fixing the issues and will
have to resubmit the game for testing
while there's no official word on how
that will affect the August release
window I have to imagine it'll be
delayed at least a little bit the xbox
one version of Minecraft is also
projected to launch in August and for
jay is fixing bugs on that version as
well before sending it off to Microsoft
for final certification call of duty
advanced warfare is coming out a few
short months but it will not be coming
out for the Wii U despite the fact that
the two previous entries in the series
black ops 2 and ghosts did make it to
Nintendo's console the sledgehammer
games developed advanced warfare will
not an Activision isn't the only
publisher who isn't big on the Wii U it
seems despite releasing last year's
Assassin's Creed for the Wii U Ubisoft
said the upcoming release of watch dogs
will be the last mature game the company
publishes for the Wii U for the
foreseeable future just can't catch a
break can you we you with your big old
tablet thingy and your mario games you
hang in there sport remember that time
microsoft said that rise of the Tomb
Raider was an Xbox exclusive but then it
wasn't an Xbox exclusive really but then
it still kind of was Microsoft's Phil
Spencer said this week that it wasn't
anything against any other platform and
went on to say I'm a big fan of
uncharted and I wish we had an action
game of that ilk we've started some and
we've looked at them but we didn't have
one today of that quality this referring
to the deal with square enix verizon and
tomb raider is an opportunity yeah an
opportunity to make non Xbox owners
really cranky apparently but don't worry
it's just a timed exclusive you'll get
to play it on other platforms later just
later when it's not cool any all right
folks it's time to round out today's top
five with a segment we like to call the
pee spot there was a steady stream of
pee news this week with multiple
developers commenting on resolution in
their games on that magic threshold
1080p Blizzard said that Diablo 3
ultimate evil edition originally ran in
1080p on the Xbox one but they knocked
it down to 900 p to ensure a liquid
smooth frame rate after microsoft
insisted
more p and pushed an xbox one code
update to help blizzard bolstered it
back up to 1080p The Witcher 3 may or
may not run in 1080p on the PlayStation
4 and Xbox one according to CD Projekt
RED it's still too early to tell how
it's going to shake out and finally
destiny production director John T
Barnes downplayed the importance of
games running in 1080p at 60 frames per
second saying it's all about the
gameplay experience for the player
destiny is slated to run at 1080p and 30
frames a second on release that's all
the P talk for today and that's a wrap
for GS news from San Francisco I'm Chris
waters and it's been a pleasure hosting
for you all this week let's do it again
sometime Jess McDonald's going to be
back next week with the news and I'll
see you during game sports coverage of
pax prime have a great weekend